someone said once she's got a fire in
her stomach and it'll never go out I
start to think about that it's probably
he's probably right I just have energy I
was born with this music icon Tina
Turner dead at 83 but that fire she
mentioned is forever burning bright I
hear so many things about Tina Turner
and I'm sure there's there's a lot in
the minds of people I just hope that
whatever is left is positive because I I
think when I look back over my life I've
lived a quite positive life in the wake
of Tina's death tributes from
Hollywood's Elite are pouring in on
social media Diana Ross shared a photo
with the legendary vocalist writing
shocked saddened sending condolences to
Tina Turner's family and loved ones
[Music]
Chaka Khan posted Tina Turner had an
album break every rule that summed up
her life and career she may have left
this plane but her spirit and voice are
immortal
[Music]
Mariah Carey shared the words that come
to mind when she thinks of Tina
legendary iconic Diva and Superstar and
added to me she will always be a
Survivor and an inspiration to women
everywhere I want to make a million
dollars
by the Sea for Alicia Keys she thanked
Tina for inspiring her to live an
authentic life the songs You Sang gave
us courage to step out and be our full
selves then there's Angela Bassett
the actress who played Tina in the 1993
biographical film What's Love Got to Do
With It reflected on Tina's life in a
statement to ET I am honored to have
known Tina Turner I am humbled to have
helped show her to the world she gave us
her whole self and Tina Turner is a gift
that will always be Simply the Best
[Music]
being this this lioness this really just
you know just wild and extemporaneous
and whatever and she just seemed to be
just to know every moment what she was
doing the audience was experiencing it
but uh she knew what was going on you
know and that was interesting she even
in that she has a lot of you know
self-respect and dignity and she was
even within that image maintaining you
know a self-respect and a dignity just
not throwing it just all out there in
the wind but a certain way that it was
presented
[Music]